okay in this lesson we're going to talk
about multiplying binomials sometimes
known as foiling and if you learn this
acronym foil it's the first outer inner
and last so if you're multiplying
binomials binomial means two terms times
two terms right the terms are separated
by plus or minus
and what you're doing is you're
multiplying the first term in this group
times the first term in this group so
that gives you 3x squared outer means
the ones towards the outside so that'd
be the x times negative 1 which is
negative 1x i means the ones that are in
the inside that's 2 times 3x which is
6x and then the last term times the last
term
which would be negative 2. so if you
combine these all together you get 3x
squared plus 5x minus 2. now you don't
have to know the foiling this is just
one way to do it the other way to do it
is just to take the x and distribute to
both of these terms and then take the 2
and then distribute it to both those
terms just do the distributive property
twice following is just an acronym to
help you remember how to do that but
let's look at a typical example that
could be seen on the act see if you can
do this one on your own and then we'll
go through it together so
if you multiply these together you get
2x squared plus x minus 28. what does
the value of k equal
okay so the way we would do this is
we could either do the distributive
property of the foiling i'll just
distribute this time so that's going to
be x times 2x which is 2x squared
x times negative k is
negative x k right and then 4 times 2 k
4 times 2 x i'm sorry is 8 x
and then 4 times negative k is a
negative 4 k
so now here if we uh
simplify this i'm going to factor out an
x here so this is going to be plus x
times negative k plus 8
minus 4 k
now if we compare
this
trinomial
with this guy here you can see that
here's your 2x squared
negative 4k equals negative 28 so k
should equal negative 7 but let's just
confirm
if we put
did i say negative 7 that's k is
positive 7 because negative 4 times 7 is
negative 28 and then if we put 7 in here
negative times 7 is negative 7 plus 8
gives us positive 1. so you can see this
is plus 1k so the answer here is going
to be k equals 7. so again it's just
having an understanding of how to
multiply binomials definitely something
you want to understand for the math
section for the act